[Music]
bishop c4
on the board so we might be seeing the
same italian line
all right so c3 play this is exactly
what happened
in aviation at some point what is it
going to be so this is all following
what we've seen so far peter
yeah but it also could be easily that
magnus will
deviate yeah uh no okay wesley deviates
with hd so that's
that's the three so let's just let's
just tell everyone what happened
in game one instead of h3 there was this
move queen c2 which was played
uh and after knight e6 being played in
that one
uh and this did not happen this time so
instead of queen c2 wesley and his team
come up with the idea of h3 kicking out
that bishop first
uh forcing it to h5 c1 is the first new
move
because uh to be fair when first time
this time appeared
i think it was kind of common knowledge
and everybody included
hd move queen b3 here in fact it turned
out that
black has the move knight a5 i think and
this is very very important because
here we see the big difference that
after queen takes d5 suddenly with the
bishop on the
e4 but after knight xd4 luke 88 you
actually
trap wide screen in the center of the
board
they were doing immediately without the
the inclusion hd bishop f5 so that's how
all this line developed because here
line kind of got abandoned and
it didn't really get any attention and
suddenly wesley comes up
and okay i don't know the first of all
the move cannot be objectively really
good because if it would be so good the
investor would have
already used it in his very first game
but maybe my situation will be desperate
than exactly with this move i'm planning
to this balance magnus
just as vajrav has done in that that was
in where he came up with this h4a5 luke
h4 line which objective
also doesn't promise might anything in
fact maybe even white is risking
something if black knows
but if blackie does not know he is uh
still thinking about that game
one we saw him just slightly unhappy
with the way things
are right now shaking his head so far
roxy one played i think in game one the
position he got out of the opening
was part of his big mess up on his side
allowing madness that attack and losing
that game one
definitely a the worst kind of start
that wesley could have expected
especially
using his key preparation
very interesting what'd you point out
that rook's five suddenly becomes a
reality although
even attacking the e5 pawn uh the
pressure is on and i think
far from over in the calculation but for
making sure the knight on c3 is tied
down
can't go to d5 so the main idea in these
structures for black is always to get f6
one way or the other
and i have a feeling that now is the
right time for white to go short castle
once again renew the idea of taking on
v5 and after shot castle i am
expecting a trade on c3 not allowing the
white troop to have an
open sea line and then eventually f6
yes castle played the f6 i mean uh it
all depends on these f but
i don't know exactly i mean not f6
doesn't seem to be so good yeah
this is the because this is another very
important strategical moment from
white's play yeah like for example after
g4 maybe first reaction is like oh my
god what is g4
why is white weakening his skin very
important to get rid of this
smacking but i just go knight e5 and
next
i'm gonna go f3 kicking this knight away
and we again see one of those positions
that white actually
wants to get in this structure like
kicking the knight of eight it might be
unpleasant so
yeah and magnus is not going f6 he goes
knight e5
black wants to set up the blockade with
c6 b5 knight c4
rely on this pin and uh be ready for
every action that white is uh trying to
use on the king side
so a super exciting position i mean we
got a real game that's that's the very
good news for us
i think wesley needs to use this
opportunity that you're talking about he
needs to go g
with f6 or go for this knight c4 idea
i am predicting g4 from wesley it's time
for him to
and he goes for repeater he'll wipe for
wesley uh the fourth game is after that
so we fixed the
scores under the under the players now
bishop g6 played
hey first the move king g2 it's it's not
entirely clear to me because
if you play knight e1 one of the moves
that bothered me a bit was f6
because neither desired move like fc
maybe can be answered by nige
but no he went back why i was also not
such a huge fan of king g2 that i wasn't
really sure that the long term smart
king is really so much better than g
than on g1 and after all it costs the
tempo
so 91 on the board and i feel like you
know okay black has to somehow justify
um i mean he has to then white will be
super happy
getting that extra tempo with the knight
g2 kicking the queen back plus then
already fc
might trap the knight on on e4 so queen
h4 looks like a nice
uh attacking move but in fact might lose
a lot of lot of tempest for black
unfortunately he goes for f6 yeah he
doesn't want to touch the
f3 is screaming to be played uh peter
let's take a look at that because if
white trades on f6 that solves all of
black's problem if white goes f4
black's f6 is super successful i'm
expecting uh
wesley good or bad to play the move f3
here
yeah fc is kind of expected now i'm also
thinking that
can actually black be super clever and
then try to play c6 here
yeah fc on the board so wesley bites the
bullet he says he's ready for it ready
for all the action because that's what
he needs with the white pieces right now
what
is a massive position it's it's a type
of position where magnus is this
balanced
it's not like he can rely on any of his
routines or or whatever i mean it's a
very very concrete direct position
a lot of pressure on modules now peter
let's take a look at some lines because
this is such a critical moment and
magnus down to six minutes on his clock
he can't take too long
because the action regardless white is
doing well here
c6 first big question where does the
bishop go to i don't want to come back
to e2 because of knight g3
let's take a look at bishop d3 and what
happens
what's the follow-up after bishop d3
yeah and magnus has
actually opted for c6 i think it was
kind of the justification that
if he already played for this f6 line
then he wants to follow it up with c6 it
spices that
black will be able to trade down the
light square bishops immediately
okay so night light square bishop where
is this knight on g3 escaping to and the
answer to that is nowhere
so you don't want to take chances with
that knight g5 played
and now yes but those
type of positions are super tricky
because
actually black solves a lot of lot of
problems he hinders
because i don't think we get we get the
chance to actually look at such a pawn
structure where there are four pawns
on the same line on the g line three
black pawns
uh a triple decker here but like you
were mentioning that black has his own
trumps
after winning his pawn structure exactly
the point is that uh
also white's knight will lock any good
square it's just impossible that
also big taking a closer look it doesn't
look
appealing at all for for white
the big question is like which piece do
you want to trade yeah which piece do
you want to create when do you want to
go f4
because after the white could even uh uh
maybe go for f4 just as
just as before but of course situation
has changed
now for example after f4 and we and we
are seeing this phone structure wow
wow amazing peter absolutely what you
were pointing out in the other line
huge difference from what we saw after
the bishop trade
uh in that position white would have had
f5 as it tell here f5
there's no bishop in g6 so white doesn't
really have that kind of time
so instead wesley gives magnus
the worst pawn structure that we've seen
in the ftx crypto cup so far
yeah but it's also very very interesting
to understand what
vastly is thinking yeah because knights
knight c4
wow magnus magnus felt that you know
going knight c4 immediately giving the
g6 spawn
magnus felt that he doesn't have the
right to lose tempo for this move
interesting i mean i'm i'm still not
exactly understanding why
i still don't entirely understand why
this is so critical but in time to break
with f4
and one thing you don't want to do is
let whites not be activated yeah
for example g5 maybe even something like
knight g6 on g6
there are either lines like evo queen e6
i might follow it up with luke f5
you cannot take on g6 because of look fa
check
and then i'm starting to take on g5 go
look h5 and and invade and mate
so magnus gives up the pawn but this is
then the full pawn so it's not about the
we are not talking still maintains the
pressure i really like after queen g6
uh queen e7 his move rook f2 the idea is
simple you want to free up your knight
on e1 you want to start jumping around
with it
either earlier because black had this
idea of knight d2 which would hit the
rook on f1 and the pawn on f3
so first a prophylactic move preparing
to get ready to jump with the knight and
bring it into the game
yeah and not there is nothing else to do
for magnus
yeah like okay i lost the pawn i want to
try to pretend that things are
and i have to say that whenever you know
somebody makes a draw like magnus has
done in the second game i'm very very
happy that in the
next game the right player gets a chance
yeah because this is exactly the way
how we want to discourage those
decisions that
whenever black feels like i i mean
whenever the player who won with the
black pieces that says like okay and i
i won't leave what we we should be very
very happy about that
we got a very very exciting match again
knight g to look a seed
and look cf1 i actually love this move a
lot
i really love this move because white is
getting ready to break with f4 and then
the look yeah rook c6 had to be played
the queen had to be kicked away but and
this is
this is bad news for magnus i mean it's
not only that it looks bad
it might be also that practically it's
just so easy for wesley as a clear plan
and it's the right way to go with f4
and okay six very clever by magnus he
doesn't want to give breeder
advance into kc it might be that it's
still okay for white but definitely you
need to calculate a lot because
black will be hitting the pawn on hc and
unless you see
exactly that by force you are doing very
well you don't want to give such
chance peter i just mentioned
in chat that i'm actually expecting
wesley to win this one he's got this
extra pawn bit
and look at that eval bar it does seem
to say that white has got this huge
advantage and
the only thing that in that rare
position of
game four how white set it up and in the
end finished it off the moment he opened
the f5
and this is the same pattern that we are
seeing here from wesley's side
one here so that after uk you will be
ready to play luke bc and it's
again a very very typical natural way of
you know rebooting your your look and
then you can ask me
why was i so awful about to look c1 to
f1 before
but a lot of things has changed yeah
because after that
took on d4 i know that my opponent
already took i'm coming back with the
queen
now black is leaving the c file he's
going rk6
and then the move like rook b1 just
preventing all these
ideas on the queen side make a lot of
sense but
definitely one of the things for the
screen and peter we are being
a lot of chat mentioning that f4 seems
to be the move that the
engine is recommending so maybe let's
take a look at that yeah you go back to
g6
and now the point is that after the move
rook takes hd
probably you can just take on g5 ah f6
might be winning there but okay anyway
f4 on the board we might be seeing all
these lines
f4 okay three queen g6 blitzed out
so if f4 it and rook a3 queen g6
peter rook h3 you definitely don't want
that
even if f6 is a possibility i think this
line should not work for white
so after rook h3
after white is not winning here but the
point is that
after f5 i'm also not sure if but
okay otherwise f5 anyway has this
terrible f6 that yeah magnus going for
luke takes ch3 so
they might be seeing f5 or f3 g5 one of
these two moves
in the beginning i just thought simply
take on g5 and you've got control of the
f5 you've got
rook f2 rook f2 e6 maybe coming in with
ideas of rook f7
knight my difficult to deal with it
knight e3 you're mentioning
at the moment and does this give white
does this mean that white would be
forced to fight queen g5 yeah queen
disney queen g5 and
okay maybe you have rookie too i don't
know but it it already looks
looks strange vastly going for f5 i mean
it's a very principled move i mean
humanly this is very nice because you
have this
wonderful pawn structure and you don't
butcher with f6
making sure that you use your
two rooks on the f file and with
incredible force and let's not forget
that in the very first game where magnus
won
with the black pieces he won thanks to
these two rooks nice well to check me in
black
and chat informing us peter that f5 is
the way to go now rook 86 was the scary
thing the first moment you look at it
but i think
this you just go slightly deeper in that
position
and actually after rook 86 f6 it's black
who's in big trouble
because take a look at this if black
picks up the queen on g6 white takes
fe7 and you can't really stop the e7
pawn from promoting
take white's queen on g6 on the other
hand if after f6 you simply move your
queen away let's say to d7
or to c7 amongst other options queen g5
looks like the simplest way to continue
in that position
so rook 86 isn't it is not possible
after f5
actually if while gets f-16 it's just
winning so i'm wondering
can black take on e4 c5
queen e5 with with some counter play but
queen e6 you just trade the queens
immediately no
oh yes yeah no of course maybe you have
a lot of bonds
yeah but i mean okay no if by magnus
then f6 i mean why isn't i just
crashing through it looks like white is
crushing
wow okay so f6 ef-6 just saw this
this just blundered it completely he
just blocked